ก็
สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนได้ค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะ
คือหญิงสวัสดีค่ะเพื่อนที่ค่ะการก็มาเจอ
กับเรา 2 คนครูหญิงเราก็ครูฟ้าค่ะชื่อเรา
ได้แล้วเยอะจำได้ไหมถ้าใครทำได้ก็ดีใจอ่ะ
คะถ้าใครยังไม่รู้จักรู้ฟ้านะคะแล้วก็ครู
หญิงจริงๆใช่แล้วน้องก็ช่วยการช่วงนี้
เป็นบีกินเนอร์ 3 ชั่วโมงดีกินได้แล้ววัน
นี้เนี่ยเราสองคนจะมาคุยกันเกี่ยวจั๊บ
กับอะไรรู้มั้ย
ฮะผลไม้
ชายมีน้องนี่คือนี้เป็นอันนี้ถักในครับ
ถัดนักเรียนโอ๊ยลูกฉันจะเป็นกล่องนะคะ
กล่องพรีเมียร์ลูกผักนะไม่ใช่พันธุ์ของ
จริงหรอค่ะ
ส่วนกล่องนี้ก็คือ
ผลไม้
มันเป็นรับเป็นผลไม้
วันนี้เราจะมาคุยกันเกี่ยวกับ
ขาดหรือ
ผลไม้
ไม้เพราะว่าอย่างเราสองคนเนี่ยเคยเป็นครู
สวยเมื่อก่อนเราเป็นครูหน้าเราก็เคยได้
ยินว่าบางอย่างเนี่ยในประเทศไทยกับประเทศ
นักเรียนคิดไม่เหมือนกัน
คิดไม่เหมือนกันใช่ค่ะว่าบางครั้งประเทศ
ไทยคิดเป็นถักประเทศนักเรียนอาจจะอเมริกา
อังกฤษฝรั่งเศส
ในญี่ปุ่นเนี่ยคิดถ้าครูไม่ใช่ทักมันคือ
ผลไม้
อยากรู้มากเลย
นะเอาวันนี้เราก็เลยจะมาคุยกันแต่เรามาดู
ของมาดูอันที่ 1 ก่อนแล้วกันนะคะครูฟ้า
ได้ค่ะคิดว่าเหมือนกันทุกประเทศก็คือ
แอปเปิ้ล
แอปเปิ้ลครูฟ้าคะแอปเปิ้ลเนี่ยเป็นผัก
หรือผลไม้
แอปเปิ้ลเนี่ยเป็นผลไม้ค่ะอายประเทศไทย
นี่ผลไม้
ประเทศนักเรียนก็น่าจะผลไม้ใช่ไหมสายหน่อ
ไม้เหมือนกันนะคะหรือว่าสัปปะรดใช่ไหมคะ
สับปะรดเนี่ย
คนไทยเนี่ยคิดว่าเป็น
ผักหรือผลไม้
เป็นผลไม้ค่ะเหมือน
เปิ้ลเหมือนกันอีกอย่างนึงที่ประเทศไทยก็
คิดว่าเป็นผลไม้ให้นักเรียนเข้าใจผลไม้
ก่อนนะคะนั้นก็คืออะไรคะครูฟ้า
กล้วยค่ะกล้วย
ถ้ากล้วยนะคะกล้วยก็เป็นผลไม้
นางเป็นผลไม้เหมือนกันอาจารย์
กินเนาะ
อินทัสกินทำไมกลับหัวรูปเลยครับ
กินแล้วหาย
เปิ้ล Apple งั้น
สับปะรดแล้วก็กล้วยใช่ไหมคะกล้วยหน้าทั้ง
หมดเป็นและผลไม้เองผลไม้กินง่ายๆค่ะผลไม้
อร่อยค่ะ
กินคนละไม้นะโว้ยอร่อยแต่ถ้าทักเนี่ย
เดี๋ยวอร่อยเวลาหน้าหน้าครูฟ้ากินผลไม้
ไม่มีผลไม้เนี่ยหน้าครูฟ้ากินผลไม้เก่ง
ยังไงคะพรุ่งนี้
ว่าให้เอามีความสุขมีความสุขมากจำได้เนาะ
อาจจะที่แล้วจะไม่มีความ
รอยอร่อยแต่ถ้าเป็นผัก
ไม่ชอบคิดนะไม่ชอบคิดมากไวอร่อย
แต่เรามาดูกันว่าอะไรบ้างน้องที่เป็นผัด
นะคะอะแตงกวาสมัยแตงกวาเนี่ยเป็นผักใช่
มั้ยฮะฟ้าๆค่ะขอใกล้ๆนิดนึงค่ะคุณมีแตง
กวาใช่มั้ยมากเป็นภาพๆต่อไปอะไรคะก็ฟ้า
แครอทใช่ไหมคะแครอทเนี่ยเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
เป็นผักค่ะอันนี้นะคะกับหัวนะคะถัก
ต่อไปนะคะทุ่งฟ้า
บล็อคโคลี่
บล็อคเคอรี่นกเคอรี่เป็นผักหรือผลไม้
บล็อคเคอรี่เป็นผักค่ะน้ำเป็นผักเป็นผัก
ฟักทอง
ฟักทองฟักทองเนี่ยเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
[เพลง]
เป็นผักไหมมีใครอยู่ฟักทองดูว่ากินไหม
ฟักทอง
ไว้ได้ไม่ได้
ใกล้ๆๆเพราะตัวอย่างผู้หญิงถามครูฟ้าใช่
มั้ยเพราะผู้หญิงทำไฟฟ้าว่า
ตอนแรกก็แม็กซ์แอปเปิ้ลเป็นหักหรือผลไม้
กูฟ้าบ่ผลไม้ค่ะผลไม้ค่ะผลไม้ค่ะใช่ไหมคะ
แต่พอเป็น
แครอทใช่ไหมสีฟ้าก็บอกถ้าผักผัดอ่ะแล้วพอ
เป็นฟักทอง
ay  ay
ผักหรือผลไม้น่าจะเป็นผัก
เป็นผักเหมือนกูฟ้าบอกว่าไม่มีใครหยิบฟัก
ทองมาแล้วก็
ใช่จะกินพักทองเป็นผักนะคะนั้นในประเทศ
ไทย
ต่อไปค่ะอันนี้คือคิดว่าทั้งผักสมัยคะ
ทั้งถาดแล้วก็ผลไม้น้องคนไม้ที่เรามาให้
นักเรียนดูเนี่ยทุกๆประเทศคิดเหมือนกัน
ทำไมแอปเปิ้ลผลไม้
แครอทผัดสวยเป็นผักค่ะแต่ว่ามันมีบางยา
บางชนิดที่เราเคยคุยกับนักเรียนแล้วนัก
เรียนบอกว่า
ทำไมทำไมคนไทยคิดเป็นผลไม้หรือทำไมคนไทย
คิดเป็นผัก
ทำใบคิดไม่เหมือนกันไม่ไหวเหมือนกันมึง
เพราะว่านักเรียนต้องรู้เนาะอาจจะต้องรู้
นิดหน่อยแต่เวลาไปคุยกับคนไทยแล้วก็ใช้
ของก็มันก็จะได้เข้าใจว่าเราสองคนเนี่ย
บอกแล้วน้องอ่ะอันแรกเลยค่ะครูฟ้า
อะไรคะ
มะเขือเทศค่ะอ่ะมือถืออะเทศมะเขือเทศนี่
คือฟ้าชอบกินใบนะจำไม่ได้อ่ะก็กินทางปลา
ชอบกินน้ำเลิกพี่
ประเชิญหน้า
จากวีดีโอแรกนะที่เราคุยกันอ่ะครูฟ้าคะ
ที่ประเทศไทยมะเขือเทศเรานักเรียนเห็นใช่
ไหมคะมะเขือเทศเนี่ยเป็น
ถากหรือว่าผลไม้คะ
มะเขือเทศเป็นผักขันคน
มะเขือเทศเป็นผักค่า
ประเทศไทยณประเทศไทยมะเขือเทศเป็นพระ
ผลไม้
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมะเขือเทศเป็นผัด
กินกับสลัดล่ะ
กินกับสลัดหรือว่ากินในส้มตำใช่มั้ยไปย่า
ป๊อกๆและก็ไปขึ้นใส่
เป็นผักค่ะกินบ่เป็นผักๆเพราะว่าฉันเคย
ได้ยินเนาะบางประเทศคิดมะเขือเทศเนี่ยไม่
ใช่ทาน
มะเขือเทศเป็นผลไม้
เหมือนๆเหมือนๆแอปเปิ้ลเนี่ยเปิ้ลเป็น
ผลไม้ใช่ไหมบางประเทศบอกว่ามะเขือเทศเป็น
ผลไม้
[เพลง]
คนไทยก็บอกไม่ใช่
นักเรีนถ่ายถ้านักเรียนไปเดิน
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตทำไมจะไปซื้อของถ้าคิดจะ
ซื้อมะเขือเทศมะเขือเทศก็จะอยู่โซนผัก
นี่ว่าประเทศไทยในเมื่อเขือเทศจึงค่ะๆไม่
ได้ไม่ใช่ผลไม้ฮะก็คนไทยเนี่ยกินมะเขือ
เทศใช่ไหมอยากกินมะเขือเทศแบบเอาไปทำ
อาหาร
ใช่เออบอกก็อาจจะมีกินมะเขือเทศแบบหยิบ
กินนิดหน่อยไหมมีแผลส่วนใหญ่เออส่วนใหญ่
มะเขือเทศเนี่ยคนไทยเอาไปทำอาหาร
สปาเกตตี้สลัดถ้าต้องตำส้มตำมาเป็นอาหาร
ได้เราก็เลยคิดว่ามะเขือเทศเนี่ยเป็นผัก
เพราะเราเอาไปทำอาหารในห่างฉันไม่ใช่
ผลไม้เราไม่ได้คิดเหมือนเหมือนๆนักเรียน
สวยนักเรียนอาจจะดูเป็นแบบซะแย่งใช่ไหม
เป็นอะไรไบโอโลจี้เหรอ
ตัวแล้วก็บอกก็
ผลไม้ผลไม้แต่คนไทยเนี่ยไม่ใช่คนไทยดู
แอปเปิ้ล
กินได้เลยค่ะดอกไม้แล้วก็อร่อยช่วยกว่า
เราไหมอะไรอ่ะแด่มะเขือเทศเนี่ยเอาไปทำ
อาหาร
ผักเป็นผักที่ประเทศไทยมะเขือเทศเป็นผัก
น็อต
ต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าตอบอะไรคะ
มะนาวก่อนคน
มะนาวค่ะ
จะคิดว่าผู้หญิงมะนาวมะนาวเป็นพักใช่ไหม
คะให้ต้นทางเราเป็นผักเรากินมะนาวหรอแบบ
กิน
เราแต่เป็นผักอ่ะเอาไปทำอาหารเหมือนกัน
ใส่ค่ะใช่ไหมคะอะไรได้ไทยเนี่ยมะนาวเป็น
ผักไม่ใช่ผลไม้
ประเทศนักเรียนมะนาวเป็นผลไม้หรอเขาก็บอก
ว่าเหมือนเหมือนๆเหมือนส้ม
มา
รู้จักส้มสีส้มผู้หญิงน่าจะไม่มีส้มแน่
เลย
ส้มใช่ไหมส่งที่รัฐใช่และแบ่งออกมาใช่ไหม
ซองแซนวิช
ส้ม
เล็กๆกันนะส้มนี่ๆส้มประเทศนักเรียนบอก
ว่ามะนาวเนี่ยเหมือนส้มอีกหลายเป็นเป็น
เพื่อนเป็นแฟนลี่เดียวกันปีที่เดียวกันจะ
ไม่เหมือนส้มก็เลยไม่ใช่ผัก
ไม่รู้นะถ้าประเทศไหนคิดเหมือนคนไทยบอก
ได้นะบอกได้
เพราะว่าทำไมคนไทยคิดว่ามะนาวเป็นผัก
มันอาหารใช่เอาไปทำอาหารค่ะแล้วก็มันกิน
แบบ
แบบกินแบบเอาไม่ได้เอาไปพาสเจอร์ไรส์
เดี๋ยวไปทำอาหารก็หยิบขึ้นมาใช่ไหมค่ะ
แล้วก็กินเลยเนี่ยมันไม่ได้ไปได้ถ้าเรียว
ฉันคน
เราไม่ยอมอะ
แล้วเราก็มันเอาไปทำอาหารใช่ไหมเราก็คิด
ออกไม่เอาเป็นผัดน้องไปซื้อได้ไม่มี
บล๊อคโคลี่มีแครอทมีมะนาวอยู่ด้วยกันแล้ว
ก็ได้ไทยเนี่ยคิดว่ามะนาวเป็นผักนะคะนัก
เรียนไปหาเรียนต่อไปค่ะอะไรคะครูฟ้า
อะโวคาโดค่ะเออ
อะโวคาโดอะโวคาโดเนี่ย
อันนี้อ่านมานั้นในอินเตอร์เน็ต internet
บอกว่าเป็นผลไม้
ขอเป็นผลไม้อ่า
แต่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยคนไทยเนาะคนไทยคิดว่า
อะโวคาโด้เป็นผัดหรือผลไม้คะครูฟ้า
มีคนไทยคิดว่าอะโวคาโด้เป็นผักค่ะผัก
ทำไมอ่ะขอดูก็กินได้นะนักเรียนอาจจะไม่
ถามยังไงเอาอะโวคาโดมาแล้วก็
กินได้เลย
ทำไมไม่เป็นผลไม้ใช่ไหมอะโวคาโดก็เหมือนๆ
กับ Apple  White  Apple กินได้เลยก็
กินได้เลยว่าอาโวคาโดไม่ใช่ของไทยใช่มะ
ใช่ไม่ใช่ของไทยประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยไม่มีโอคาโด้ไงแล้วก็คนไทยก็เลย
ไม่ค่อยกิน
อโวคาโดแล้วเวลาคนไทยกินอนสวะ
มันจืดใช่ไหมครับอย่าง Apple น่ะมึงอร่อย
เอาไว้แต่อะโวคาโด
ไม่
แล้วก็เสร็จแล้วมันก็จะมีอาหารอาหาร
เม็กซิโกไหมไม่แน่ใจนะคะจี้เค้าจะมีชิป
แล้วก็กินกับอะโวคาโดทำไมมีอโวคาโดเหมือน
เป็นอาหารเม็กซิโกซึ่งคนไทยก็เลยคิดว่า
อ๋อเอาโอคาโด้เนี่ยทำอาหารสมัยทำอาหารก็
มึงเป็นผักเหมือน
มะนาวเหมือนมะเขือเทศไปเอาไปทำอาหารก็เลย
เป็นผักเหมือนกัน
แต่ว่า
ไม่รู้น่าจะเดินได้ให้ใส่เป็นภาษาสำหรับ
คนไทยคิดนะคะคนไทยคิดสายถ้านักเรียนไปถาม
คนไทยเราก็บอกว่าทำไมเอาโอคาโด้อยู่ในโซน
ผัดใจถ้าไปเดินซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตแล้วคก็
อยากจะซื้ออะโวคาโดก็นักเรียนก็อาจจะไป
เดินแล้วก็เจอ Apple  Strawberry
Cherry
ทำไมไม่มีอโวคาโด
แต่เวลานักเรียนเดินไปออกแครอทบล็อกโคลี่
อะโวคาโดทำไมอะโวคาโดอยู่กับขัดใจว่า
ประเทศไทยเราคิดอะโวคาโดเป็นผัก
ชายค่ะเพราะเวลากูฟ้ากินอะโวคาโดหน้าเป็น
ยังไงคะ
ผู้พายคิดว่าไม่อร่อยเลยแต่ถ้ากูฟ้ากิน
สตรอเบอรี่บลูเบอรี่เพลงผลไม้เฮิร์ตอ
เบอร์รี่เป็นผลไม้
เวลากินให้อ้ำอร่อย
เออจริงๆอาจจะไม่ได้เกี่ยวกับทำอาหาร
อย่างเดียวเวลากินด้วยเนาะคือเวลาแบบ
ผลไม้เนี่ยไม่ว่าอีกหนึ่งสะตอสตอเบอรี่
แอปเปิ้ลเชอรี่เนี่ยเราซื้อมาแล้วก็
กินได้เลยแล้วก็อร่อยแต่มะเขือเทศมันเกิด
เทศอ่ามะนาวหรือ
อะโวคาโดบางครั้งเราซื้อมาต้องทำอาหาร
ก่อนนายน้ำแล้วก็เอามากินหรือว่าซื้อมา
แล้วก็เอามากินมันก็แบบ
ไม่อร่อยแล้วเราก็คิดไม่ใช่ผลไม้ใช่ไหมจะ
ดูแล้วก็เอามาทำอาหารในคิดง่ายๆไม่ได้ไม่
หลับไปเรียนมาใช่ฮะก็ไม่เหมือนกันใช่ไหม
เพราะนักเรียนอาจจะกินอะโวคาโดเป็นผลไม้
ใช่ไหมคะค่ะและอเมริกาอังกฤษ
ฟีแลนเซอร์แลนน่าจะกินหะโวคาโด้คนละก็จะ
ประเทศไทยประเทศไทยไม่ใช่เป็นผักเดินผัก
จ่ายก็ถ้าประเทศนักเรียนคิดเหมือนประเทศ
ไทยหรือคิดไม่เหมือนกันก็คอมเม้นใช่ไหม
คอมเม้นท์บอกได้สมัยว่าจะผู้หญิงครูฟ้า
ประเทศชั้นเนี่ยคิดเหมือนประเทศไทย
อาโวคาโด
เป็นผักมาเล่นทันจ้าได้หรืออาจจะบอกว่า
อะโวคาโด้สายพานอะโวคาโดเป็นผลไม้
คอมเม้นที่คอมเม้นบอกเราได้ใจว่าเป็นผัก
หรือผลไม้น้องเราจะได้เข้าใจหลายๆประเทศ
ใช้ว่าไอ้คิดเหมือนเราหรือเปล่า
comment ค่ะเข้าไปใจน้ำเงินคอมเมนต์คุย
กันได้น้องนี่แต่ก่อนที่ไปมีอินดึงยางพี่
อีกหนึ่งชนิดเลยผู้หญิงเข้าพูด
ติดน่ากินข้าวโพดเค้าพูดเนี่ยเป็นผ่าตัด
หรือผลไม้
ผักหรือผลไม้
ครูฟ้าครูข้าคิดว่าเขาโพดนะคะข้าวโพด
สำหรับครูฟ้านะทรงฟ้าคิดว่าเข้าข้นเป็น
ผักหรือผลไม้
เข้าประเทศไทยทำอาหารก็ได้
เลยก็ได้
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
คิดว่าข้าวโพดเป็นผักเป็นภาษานเป็นหัว
หน้าน่า
รักกล่องภาคอะเดี๋ยวก็เขียนหัดมีข้าวโพด
ด้วยก็มีกะโพสต์มีมีพริก
ก็เป็นผัก
เป็นผักใช่ไหมแต่เราก็กินแล้วเค้าพูดหรือ
แบบหยิบมาแล้วก็กินซะมันก็ไปทำอาหารได้นะ
มันหวานมันไม่ไหวอร่อยนะกูฟ้าเวลากินข้าว
โพดเนี่ย
[เพลง]
อร่อยก็เป็นกันผลไม้ได้นะหรอเด้อ
หรอไม่รู้ผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้
แต่คนไทยคิดว่าเป็นผักใช่ไหมคะ
บางครั้งคนไทยก็มีคำถามนะว่าเอ๊ะข้าวโพด
เวลาเสิร์ชใน Google เนี่ยค่ะว่าข้าวโพด
เป็นผักหรือผลไม้ไม่ทันหรือผลไม้ไม่รู้
เหมือนกันเนาะอา homework เรียน
นักเรียนดูวีดีโอเสร็จแล้วก็เม้นบอกเรา
ได้อีกเหมือนกันว่านะเขาโพด
ใช่ไหมคะเข้าโพดเนี่ยเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
น้องหรือไม่ใช่ผัดไม่ใช่ผลไม้ก็อ้างบอก
ได้ว่าเขาโพดคืออะไรเอา OT อะไรสีใหม่ล่ะ
เขาก็
หิวชิไม่รู้น้องใจก็บอกเราได้เนาะวันนี้
เราสองคนก็หมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมค้าแล้วมาเจอ
กันคลิปวีดีโอหน้าขาไทยไปก็อย่าลืมกดไลน์
กดแชร์กด Subscribe แล้วก็เปิด
Notification ด้วยนะคะพี่พรไปแล้วจะได้
มาเจอกับเรา 2 คนอีกวันนี้ไปก่อนแล้วค่ะ
บ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายๆก็สวัสดีค่ะ
ไอ้ฟาย